at the end of our podcast we do a thing
called unhelpful advice
was it really oh man you know what there
was one thing i wanted to talk to you
guys about but
we never get uh all right go ahead
do it yeah
you forget no it's just something that's
going on right now then
that would be interesting because you
know you have uh medical expertise and
it would just
i don't oh well then just try let's give
it a try so i've been dealing with some
some medical stuff with my hormones
being very all over the place
all my hormones and i've been visiting
i've been seeing doctors and mris and
cat scans and all these things and
recently i went to uh uh whatever the
penis doctor is
for fertility and stuff who has a
specialty in endocrinology especially
with with uh testosterone not all
hormones with testosterone and uh
he wasn't sure and i have to go to the
geneticist for more tests and stuff but
i'm just taking my time because of
the world and he told me that uh
a lot of ashkenazi jews not a lot of but
of this condition that he's about to
tell me of the majority of the muskenity
jews i don't remember the name of it but
it's something where i'm basically
i'm a one i'm a man and a woman not
hermaphrodite it's something else i
i'm a woman i'm not a man and a woman
i'm a woman i'm a woman with a penis and
you know which is totally fine and i
support that this is how it starts
but it was just like well i'm not
a woman hormonally on paper is what
they're saying
is his hypothesis okay uh and i was born
a certain way
and whatever and it's like okay i'm not
i'm not but like
let's do the test right but then uh
uh as more things are going down and
betty is helping try to figure out and
diagnose like
some things are possible but that means
we would never be able to get pregnant
because i have i have a varicocele on my
left testicle shout out to varicoceles
and um i had one when i was uh in the
11th grade i had an operation
it went away i then got a girlfriend
pregnant and
things happened we felt was both for us
at the time and i think it's great that
a woman
or a man if there's a choice with their
body and you know you should vote
and we're all about abortions on this
podcast
and uh so i've gotten a person pregnant
yes and mazel thank you and then the
varicocele came back so i always thought
you get rid of the varicocele when
you're ready to have a baby because i
was told
it's not going to get any worse just why
have it now yeah
but now it turns out if if i'm a woman
i've never gotten somebody pre so i want
to so i'm thinking did i
did she was she pregnant with somebody
else wait so now they're saying
that it's an impossibility that you with
being a woman being a woman or with post
varicocele
that you impregnated a woman yeah so so
basically
if you couldn't get bobby pregnant right
varicocele or not okay so
oh did she this is what you wanted to
talk about this is important i want to
hear this story so basically i have to
find out if i get somebody pregnant
that's a change
this is your clothing yeah it changes
your diagnosis yeah yeah
so what am i going to reach out to her
yes and say hey did this she did yeah so
i did it'd be like okay i did and
this just happened this this was last
night and she wrote back to me this
morning and what did she say
how wait hang on you'll have to go to
rick glassman.com to find out all right
okay wait instagram okay but what did
you say how did is this how did you even
broach the subject have you spoken to
her in a long time or were you just like
hey what's up did you cheat on me
i could read it to you please do you
know what he's talking about by the way
bobby what it looks like i have no idea
what's going on this is what it looks
like
let me see that's not well that's a
varicocele but
let me see what is that one no basically
a varicocele is is a is a group of veins
it's like a varicose veins yeah so it's
basically veins around the testicle and
because veins
are filled with blood and it's warm it
makes the the the temperature of my
testicles um
spicy ah extra hot yeah but it looked
like there was only
you know there was only one ball in
there
one testicle is a little smaller than
the other oh it was basically boiling
his sperm
yeah correct well you know yes
you know that's actually exactly what it
is
your testicles are like one of them's
winking if they were eyes
yeah i would think more of one of them
one of them is more looking into uh
into one of those things a magnet like a
magnifying glass a magnifying glass
that's what it is that's a microscope
magnifying is a habit yeah yeah because
i'll be honest
because why not there's glass here it's
significantly smaller
but how's the dick it's uh it's my
girlfriend even said to me
when my doctor said are you a woman she
said her first thing did he see your
penis
because i it's great it's great i'm sure
it is
it's great i'm sure it is so i just
thought it was an interesting
subject i want to know what the email is
no this is important
this is the unhelpful advice i think uh
so here it is here's me reaching out to
a girlfriend i had a while ago asking uh
if she cheated on me all right all right
oh my gosh hey
name how have you been gotta ask
what she can be i've been good hang on
you didn't address her by her name yeah
i didn't say hey name i'm just
my god babe yeah hey whatever you are
yeah okay
no i just don't want to put her on blast
okay
she's a very famous movie star now okay
hey is she really no no no no oh okay i
would tell you the name if it was
how have you been i have an odd question
to ask you that's really important to me
okay making it about me so she doesn't
feel defensive
let him hear the data as i'm sure you
remember almost 15 years ago while we
were together you got pregnant we
handled it the way we felt best at the
time
great today i'm running into some
interesting biological questions
involving my genetics hormones
infertility
tldr ghf
all right go ahead basically if i have
ever gotten someone
you know what i'm now finishing we want
to
read it super fast take your time but
what i just want to say real quick
is why even text who gives a [ __ ] let it
go
because if if i didn't get her why would
you care about it because if i didn't
get her pregnant
oh who cares because he's trying to have
a baby let me answer
let me answer i'm trying to have a baby
if you're going to ask me a question
let me answer if you're going to make a
judgmental joke but end it with a
[ __ ] period or exclamation point
okay but whatever happened in the past
then deal with the president
and that's what i'm doing but in this
case the past absolutely
is pertinent to his future yes this is
necessary continue
go ahead my bad continue my
my bad go ahead finish i'm going to
start from the beginning
you know i don't really know what you're
saying why would you
you're [ __ ] there's birds floating
around your head yeah yeah
so go ahead send this to me we'll
animate the birds
i'm feeling i'm feeling like i'm doing a
stand up right now and now the audience
got into the
but it's not even a joke i'm curious
keep going i'm really curious i'm really
curious it's educational for me so
please continue
yeah so hello hello nate
fill in the name yes yeah hello how have
you been i remember
okay i memorized it can i give you the
short version of it have you been
what's up remember i got you pregnant
and then now we continue
continue go ahead remember we got a
shmooshmorsh
and then this continues picks up from
there
as i'm sure you remember almost 15 years
ago
while we were together we got you got
pregnant and i
um here we go yeah today i'm running
into some interesting biological
questions
genetics hormones fertility and
basically if i've ever gotten someone
pregnant it would help narrow a lot of
things down and without going into too
much detail this isn't just about
fertility this is about a lot of things
involving my body and as uncomfortable
of a question as this may seem to you
the only thing that matters
is the data i mean nothing personally
nor do i have any judgment whatsoever
it's just a couple of things that come
up recently that have contradicted the
reality of me getting somebody pregnant
ever
so my question to you and again no
judgment is
when you got pregnant while we were
together is was i the person who got you
pregnant
is there any chance it could have been
with someone else
it's really important that i know for
sure again i can't stress enough
respectfully this has nothing to do with
you
very good very good so much time so much
time has passed and if you slept with
somebody else or you're when you're 20
years old
who cares i even capitalized who cares
because i didn't know how to spell
okay okay yes
boycott
[Laughter]
okay i want to make sure you understand
i'm not accusing you of anything again
and i apologize for over communicating
i would be asking this question to
anybody it's just that it is
contradicting certain diagnosis that i
have been getting
and this is about my overall health and
i hope you'll be completely candid with
me
okay sorry she didn't respond sorry for
such a random and odd message but if
there's even a one percent chance you
got praying for somebody else that is
information it'll be valuable to me i
hope you're doing well
and thank you for your patience in
reading such an odd long message she
wrote back dear rick
i've been waiting for this
i cheated on you
no no no no no no no didn't she said you
didn't cheat
so you're not a woman i mean all the
you know i'll be honest with you all
this time i felt like i was turning into
my mother
what did it say uh she said no i'm not
gonna it's fine
but i'm just not gonna read her message
just because it feels like that's not
for me to read yeah
but i didn't cheat on you and uh she
said that um
she said everything's blah blah blah
blah you know have you been she's having
a uh
having a baby boy soon and uh wonderful
man she's moving
may i talk and i want to write back i
want to just end with this i just want
to write you my friend
funny response okay uh she said uh
i'm expecting a baby boy in you know
this month blah blah blah i said
congratulations will this be your third
i hate to ask and i'm sorry if this
feels too personal but is this baby mine
just to show like lighten up the mood
very funny
anyway it goes on very good maybe we'll
get coffee
yeah so you're like a it's you know
you're like
spock and everyone is around you it's
like bones
you know the character or the yeah the
actual character
right it's like you come into my podcast